[Music]
well mrs kloss makes the best pancakes
wait i thought you guys only ate cookies
oh we eat more than just cookies
merry christmas
hey santa hey
[Music]
hello i'm santa claus you can find me at
the north pole
oh i'm santa claus
i'm santa david and you can find me at
the north pole
i'm santa curtis and you can find me at
the north pole santa chuck
each santa has their own
own belly laugh
[Laughter]
one at a time chuck first
i say beards
beards
real nice long thick beards our priority
which we all have we all have them don't
forget
yeah
yeah yeah this is had me on a diet for
the last few seasons she has me on one
too it's a new cookie it's called paleo
santa claus is no stranger to dieting
i like just ordinary chocolate chip
cookies yeah i like snickerdoodles
okay i'll do snickerdoodles do you fist
bump there santa you do right how about
costumes i don't wear a costume and i
wear a very nice suit i like the vest
mrs claus made you that oh it's great
nice and you know i asked myself to get
me a candy cane in my suit and they just
gave me a little candy cane i said well
i want to sanitize so they got me this
okay
and this is in the pocket of my suit
wherever i go i carry a nine foot candy
cane
that's enough to keep me in snacks
yeah
i really like that buckle sam that is a
beautiful very nice buckle and i think
it sort of goes along with my magic key
that's a magic key i've seen a bunch of
them you know we get asked this a lot of
children live where there's no chimney
well santa has a magic key and can walk
right in the front door
[Music]
actually i've got one uh i was asked if
i would donate my kidney to
this young girl's aunt i have a book i
keep with prayers in it and i wrote her
name down and i told her that i'd talked
to god
for her to see if we could help get her
a kidney that was probably the hardest
one i've ever had to do
i think the hardest one i had was
a little girl asked for her dad yeah oh
yeah yeah dad was deployed to the desert
at the time a little child probably five
or six years old
and that dad was incarcerated at the
time she wanted to know if santa can
make sure he'd be be home for christmas
wow
would you tell her santa
santa will see what he can do yes
santa will see what he can do yeah last
year i had a 12 year old girl who had
just given her kidney to her
eight-year-old sister that was a very
touching virtual phone call with the
grandparents there too
but the toughest for me personally was
trying to fit a unicorn into my sack one
they don't fit and two they poop
rainbows no live animals in santa's
sleigh
i had a kid who wanted a live panda
i had to explain that it was an
endangered species
well you know what's going to be easy
for you guys i'm just going to take the
last spot over here because santa's been
losing his belly and every year i get
nasty teenagers saying i'm the skinny
santa so i'm voluntarily putting myself
here thanks to that keto cookie i think
he's got the best beard
[Laughter]
because it's all white and snowy when it
comes to outfits i have to admit i like
ears as number one i think i put you to
the front of the line sir i'm with that
come
[Laughter]
yeah i think actually i'd accept this
just the way it is
all right that was easy consensus
already
well because they're going to bring
children into children make the decision
again they're the important ones they're
the ones we've got to listen to i think
that's probably one of the biggest
qualities of santa is we actually listen
to the children hear what they're saying
to us and actually respond to them my
friend there is no greater job in the
whole world than the one we have i
absolutely agree yep
[Music]
i think there's kids our first child
merry christmas
you're wearing me i'm a santa shirt hi
santa can i take a picture sure
merry christmas so you have any
questions for us yeah um where's rudolph
rudolph right now is with the rest of
the reindeer at a secret reindeer farm
they're getting ready to start training
for uh christmas
oh
what gender is all your reindeers all
the rangers we have right now are boys
there's a lot of girl reindeers that
want to get in the race though if you
ask me but i heard all of the rangers
who were female
oh no
no dasher is a boy yeah she's a boy
dancer is a girl so is vixen vixen is a
girl too who about donner donner is a
boy
[Music]
there's
700 956 elves wow okay maybe just a few
of them
jingle susie lamont pixie dixie gunter
olaf makes the best cupcakes i think
wait i thought you guys only ate cookies
oh we eat more than just cookies
can't you tell what questions you have
for us
uh
no questions but i'm gonna try to guess
which one and which one are you the real
santa yes oh okay yeah
i think
you're the real scent
according to the quest
you're right yes
real santa
very good
i think he's a real santa claus
good job
i think
the one that's the real santa is
very nice meeting you and talking with
you so have you started working on your
christmas list yet
um actually no no
do you have an idea of maybe the the top
two things that you might want
so what would you like for christmas i
would like a
a lego set oh those are so much fun what
do you want for christmas this year um
a toy any old kind of toy
um i don't want an odor
but why didn't i see any letters last
year's christmas
there wasn't any presents that said
santa on it
you know i have to talk to the elves
because they're the ones that package
everything up and put all the labels and
all that on there you know so
i don't know what happened last year
because with covet and and all that it
was such a wild and crazy year
so i'll talk to them when i get home
okay okay
and what am i saying how old are you
really are how old am i yeah
well
i'm the same age as my tongue and older
than my back teeth
[Laughter]
i'm really old you being good
helping out mom and dad and all that
doing your chores yes
yeah good any other questions
[Music]
okay you have a good day okay bye-bye
merry christmas
like
comment like and subscribe and make sure
to ring the bell so you get a
notification whenever there's a new
episode
there you go merry christmas
[Music]